Say you have a very simple texture pattern, a checkerboard consisting of just
four texels. What happens if you put this texture on a square? There are now
many pixels all sampling the same texel. The obvious answer is that you want
this texture to continue to look like a checkerboard, with a sharp edge between
the squares. In other words, you want something like this, nice and crisp.
However, if you viewed this texture from a different angle, it doesn't look so
great. This is a zoomed-in view, just to drive home the point. You get this
stair-stepping effect instead of nice smooth edges. This is called the jaggies.
The problem is that the texture will return either black or white at every
pixel. You'd like 50 shades of gray or so, but there's only these two levels.
Sampling the texture in this way is called Nearest Neighbor. Whatever texel
center is closest to the pixel center, is the color the pixel gets. The other
option is bilinear interpolation, or linear for short. What this mode does, is
takes the four closest texel centers and interpolates among them. The closer
the pixel is to the texel center, the more of that color you get. If you turn
on bilinear interpolation this is what you get. That's definitely too much of a
good thing. You'd like blurring along the edges of the squares, but not across
the whole texture. The problem here is that one texel covers a huge number of
pixels. Let's say we aim to change this ratio to be about one texel per pixel.
In other words, say our original two by two checker pattern covers 100 by 100
pixels. To bring the ratio of texels to pixels to be closer, let's make the two
by two checker pattern be represented by an image texture of 64 by 64 texels,
so that each checker square itself covers 32 by 32 texels. In other words,
we'll just make the same pattern, but with a larger texture. Each texel in this
larger texture will now cover around one pixel. This turns out to look pretty
good. The stair steps are gone. You'll try the demo in a minute and see for
yourself. In Three.js, setting the filtering to be nearest or linear is
straightforward, there's not a lot to it. Using bilinear interpolation causes
more taps to occur, that is more texture samples to be retrieved, but it's
usually what you want. Generally, you should use Linear, which is the default.
At the same time, you want to avoid situations where a texel covers a lot of
pixels. Here's our original two by two texture. When we have a situation where
a texel covers more than a pixel, this is called magnification. When
magnification is occurring, the texture's mag filter is used. Another way to
say it is if a number of texels divided by the number of pixels is less than 1,
magnification is happening. You're magnifying the texture. Say we zoom out on
our two by two texture and it all falls within one pixel. If a texel covers
less than one pixel, that is, one pixel contains more than one texel, this
situation is called minification. In this situation the mag filter is not used.
We’ll deal with minification and how to set the corresponding Min Filter in the
next lesson. At this point I want you to study a demo as I’ll be asking you
about it. Try out various resolution textures and see how they work with
nearest neighbor and linear filtering. Try the higher resolution texture
patterns and try tilting the view to see what happens, then play with the zoom.